Some words just usually don't contain a lot of information.
And it can be really valuable to have an eye out for these words.
And to be able to just sort of remove them from your corpus, so
you don't have to to consider them.
You don't allow them to become noise in your dataset.
In general, this list of words is called stopwords.
And the exact definition of what a stopword is can vary.
But in general, it's a low information word that occurs very frequently.
Some examples might include words like and, the, I, you and have.
And a very common pre-processing step in text analysis,
is to remove the stopwords before you do anything else with the data.
Suppose that our body of stopwords is the, in, for, you, will, have and be.
Say I just give these to you and say, by fiat, these are the stock words.
My question for you in a quiz,
is how many words will be removed when we remove the stopwords from the message,
hi Katie, the machine learning class will be great.
Best, Sebastian